she's getting sent to space for him
wasn't so bad good to meet you friend
many the galaxy beep hello
oh yes oh and then we have to go and
save as go together good it is it's
amazing it's a lot of fun succeed and
saving it I can't
commence that no I'm imagining I was
getting a little a little pain I
wouldn't say too much but you can say as
much to me hey let me just say this like
every other Marvel movie it doesn't end
well for the superheroes it's truly
Marvel with it doesn't end that well
somebody always like it gets really
badly wait till you see this next one
hug everybody do do do don't do not
everybody know that no aliens or
whatever can we rewind that part yeah
can we you'll cut this that's right is
there anybody in if any award you get to
meet your tired me say am I in trouble a
little very gonna be mad at me dude I
don't I just move on I wouldn't like not
like I like glasses I would like to meet
its really interesting cuz we are all
super fine you get a little cautious hey
youtubers is Charlie happy Comic Con
week ever since d23 this past weekend in
that big Avengers infinity war panel you
guys have been messaging me about this
Mark Ruffalo comments the supposed
spoiler for infinity war so let's
explain what's going on here it's not
quite what everyone thinks people are
just reading a lot of headlines like
Mark Ruffalo spoils infinity war that's
not exactly what's going on it just a
reminder to make sure you turn alerts on
for my channel so you don't miss any of
the Comic Con videos this week the stuff
that he's talking about in the movie is
mostly Thor Ragnarok and then the
interviewer from Good Morning America
sort of segues into infinity war like
can you tell us anything cool like do
you actually get to save as guard during
Ragnarok
oh I can't really say that does anybody
actually died during infinity ward's
that's actually been a pretty big
question are they actually ballsy enough
to legit kill some Avengers and not
bring them back because most of the time
when he get questions about characters
die during infinity Wars like Hawkeye is
not a big character it's not like
they're going to do a Hawkeye so
film he'd be pretty easy to kill it's
people wondering if characters are never
going to come back and it's going to be
the end of their Marvel contract so
they'll just let vanos plow through them
on his way to assembling the Infinity
Gauntlet but Mark Ruffalo says everybody
dies
so all those interviewers that haven't
read the comics are like what does that
mean does that mean that everybody's
dead people that have read the comics
are probably like okay one he's probably
just making it offhanded remark like oh
everybody's going to get their asses
kicked or - like if you really want to
dig deep into it you could take it as
him saying that Thanos kills everyone
and then they're brought back to life
with the time gem but like know
everybody isn't going to end the movie
be dead and that's the end of it and I
think just a lot of the non comic-book
publications are picking up on that idea
like oh that's the end of the Avengers
you know big spoiler without really
realizing that that's the smallest part
of it this is meant to be Thanos quest
assembling the gauntlet the fourth
Avengers film is happening right after
that and you can't have that film
without most of those Avengers being in
it so even if on the odd chance that
Thanos really is going to kill all the
Avengers you automatically know they're
coming back so really it's a non spoiler
and Mark Ruffalo isn't drunk in this
interview he actually knows what he's
doing he's done a lot of these before so
he's not giving away anything that the
Marvel publicist that he's looking at
off screen told him he couldn't reveal
like that's what he's looking at when he
turns to the side and says can I say
that there's a Marvel publicist with a
sniper rifle pointed at him just
watching him to make sure he doesn't
reveal too much stuff
there was so much infinity war stuff
they were just hyping it up Josh Brolin
was doing the same thing where he's like
nobody has a chance against me and he
actually kind of looks like cable
because they're filming Deadpool - right
now you look at his guns they're
freaking jacked but he's holding up a
life-size replica of the Infinity
Gauntlet this is a prop that they used
during the movie so this is how big
Stannis is going to be gives you an idea
for the scope of the movie this picture
here is pretty accurate he'll be about
as big as the Hulk during the movie Mark
Ruffalo probably gave some of the best
interviews this past weekend there were
a lot of really cool things happening
but here I'll play these this is him
talking about the Hulk movie that's
never going
happen and then right after it I'll play
the Kevin Feige interview where he walks
that right back I want to just make one
thing perfectly clear today a stand
alone Hulk movie will never happen
because Universal has the rights to
stand alone Hulk movie and for some
reason they don't know how to play well
with Marvel and and they don't want to
make money and with you as the new Hulk
it would be terrible battle that's
really probably better possible we know
that these corporations would work it
out if they thought they'd make enough
money so that I think about who is
playing home but I mean I figure I got
like two or three more years left before
that I'm too old to play the whole year
and then you kind of do old man let's
just be real probably you tried to make
happen it we talked about it but I just
I don't see it in the cards you see it
in the cards no spencey I can't believe
you asked the question yeah I mean as a
little crew loved it was okay see how
I'm fine did a lot I it means a lot to
me I mean I really love this character
god I think my own I do my own thing you
know you too I mean I feel like we're
like Rosencrantz and Guildenstern a
little bit of you thanks you know very
strict Never Say Never policy but he is
correct that there no plans for isn't
there just the most beautiful thing ever
Mark Ruffalo is so on point it's never
going to happen I'm actually kind of mad
at you for bringing it up because I'm a
little salty about it like you can tell
that he's really excited about making a
Hulk solo film but Universal even Don
Cheadle Warmachine here is like
Universal apparently hates money and
they do control the distribution rights
legs they don't have the sole rights to
make a whole film but Disney doesn't
want to make a film that it can't
release itself so it's just going to
require a spider-man sharing arrangement
type of deal before they can do that and
it might not wind up happening until
after Mark Ruffalo stops playing the
character like in the distant future but
in lieu of that that's why there's so
much hulk in thor ragnarok in infinity
war they're basically saying that the
Hulk got his solo film and they just
broke it up into infinity war and Thor
Ragnarok pieces so even though infinity
war
is supposed to be a fan o space movie
like it's shot from his perspective and
you run into all the other Avengers
characters on his quest to recover the
infinity gems there's also a really big
hold thread so obviously not every
character is going to get as much screen
time as the others but it sounds like
Santos and Hulk are going to be the big
ones but let me know what you think
about this Mark Ruffalo interview do you
actually think that Thanos is going to
kill all the Avengers and then dr.
strange or someone is going to bring
them back with the time gem because I
mean that would be a badass action set
piece like it'd be an easy way to show
how insurmountable the threat of Thanos
is like they have zero chance until
they're all able to come together oh
mama I come to bargain because it sounds
like the Black Order is going to go
around and snipe all of the other
Avengers while they're off on their own
but just a reminder for comic-con
there's a bunch of TV stuff happening
this week so as long as you turn alerts
on you'll get all the videos you won't
miss anything I'm doing a Comic Con
playlist at the top of my channel so
I'll put all the new videos up there so
if you think you may have missed
something just go back and check in my
channel page I'll be posting updates on
Twitter and Facebook
Thursday is really like the first day of
Comic Con but Saturday is the big Marvel
panel so whatever trailers they draw
Black Panther Thor Ragnarok maybe an
infinity war teaser I'll totally do a
video for it but that stuff is happening
Saturday night so I'll just remind
people as I post new videos what you
wait for everything you can click here
for my breakdown of that infinity war
trailer and you can click here for the
trailer for next week's game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you